I am pleased to have on this program and
very appreciative to hear from him today
the day after that he let everybody know
that he is tested positive for Kovac 19
he's one of the greats
in the NFL today he is Denver Bronco
lineman von Miller how are you feeling
von Miller as good as I can see I don't
have like any pain or anything hurt like
I just got like as we got like a little
cough and I just mend up laying down and
just you're doing everything whatever
they tell you do you have any fever do
you have a fever right now is on its
best you know I don't have a don't have
a fever but I have it and I have been in
a steam room twice a day so I have like
a little like a little Ethernet but I
wouldn't call it like a a fever nothing
crazy it's really just it's really just
a call you know but I got a watch and
when it gets crazy I just take a
nebulizer really well I know that you
have asthma obviously even battling that
for your whole life is that have you
been in asthma an asthmatic person for
your whole life gone because right so
when did this all start walk me through
how you started feeling something that
raised a flag with you Vaughn okay we um
we were training in San Francisco we're
trained in San Francisco about a month
ago we were San Francisco's the first
city to have the armed shelter in place
order whenever they whenever they lock
down San Francisco we flew back to
Denver
oh we flew back to remember about a
month ago we had been here and number
just training I had my trainer come to
the house you know he was taking
everything serious probably left the
house four times in a month I started to
get like a call probably um probably six
tonic six days ago and my old my
girlfriend she's telling me that it
didn't it didn't sound right and I
should take her I should take a
breathing treatment
I took a breathing treatment what's up
what I normally do before like football
games and like before football games
that's the only time I take a breathing
treatment I'm gonna start taking a
breathing treatment it was
it wasn't working how it normally would
and after that another day passed and my
assistant she was like one go get tested
he was right down the street
um I'm here in Denver I went up to the
team position he took the test the next
day I start just a little bit better I
was laying down in the morning yesterday
and my team physician called me and when
he called me he said hey how are you
feeling oh that's not it might be like
the open then you know question that you
did you ask right he asked me I was out
family asked me once I said when I told
him I was you know I was sitting okay
and he told me that he got the results
back and it is a positive for : 19 so
you got tested through the Denver
Broncos is what you're saying through
your blog post
yeah okay and what is your team
physician telling you about what you
need to be mindful of here you know
there's all of this stuff is all this
stuff is doing so me you know been a day
for me um I have this I have this little
oxygen pack that I keep on it to taste
like my oxygen levels and not as long as
it stays over 90 as long as things over
90 but I have I have everything okay
with longer stays over a certain time
good that means I'm getting enough
oxygen I'm breathing right if it drops
lower than that I need to you know start
making some phone calls to get home
you know my back up so that's what I'm
that's all I'm watching right now is
just you know paying attention to this
call I'm just chilling I'm drinking you
know hot blue asti's no stuff like that
and I'm just listening to me that was
going I'm pretty much doing the same
stuff that I was doing before is now
that I have you know now that I know how
: my team yeah now that that's that's
where I wanted to ask you next von
Miller here on the Rich Eisen show
because I'm sure that many people that
might be out there listening or watching
right now be like well how careful was
was Vaughn how careful were you gone so
I was I was careful you know I I had um
you know I didn't have like my house
like completely locked down I still had
you know fish tank workers and they will
come one so we
you know you have plumbing you have
plumbing come in and then you know we
have I had a you know he had the traffic
at my house very very limited nobody was
coming in and out like I said before I
was taking it serious I was you know
keeping the number of people down that
come inside the house on the same number
of people that we had we had about I
have a lot for people you know here's
the house we we've all been you know
taking them preconscious and doing
everything that everybody's been telling
us and you know they still got us so
that's been my message to them as is my
message to like my buddies and stuff man
we you know we're taking stuff extremely
serious and I'm still you know able to
you know to get this and you know I'm
gonna I'm gonna come an unfortunate
situation I'm six minutes down the
street from the Broncos facility and I
can pick up the phone and call you know
anybody you know I got you know people
that's doing grocery runs for me and
it's a in and I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna know you know a great situation
and doing this a lot of people yes it's
not like that Oh doctor he had him here
one test for me it wasn't like you know
it's not a lot of tests going it's not a
lot of tests going around this it's
crazy out here I feel like no people
should really you know take this stuff
serious
you know I feel like I'm I feel like I'm
Superman I'd do everything to keep my
body and you know tip-top shape
you know that's my jobs do that and I
still was able to you know they correct
desire so it's very very seriously just
want people to take a serious because
it's a very nganimate von miller here on
the rich oxygen you're a 31 year olds
you're I mean your kid Vaughn I know
you're a grown-ass man on the football
field but you're 31 years old and
feeling some effects here and hopefully
the way that you're feeling now is just
the worst you're gonna get but you know
I've known some people where things can
take a turn or they can get definitely
more uncomfortable and so I'm wondering
is that why you're you're being so vocal
about it like hey you know let me start
telling people about this rather than
then not because you do clearly have a
platform and a lot of people know who
you are
Vaughn why don't you return this so
that's that's exactly it Richard you
know before I was kind of you know stay
away and you know just stay here at home
I didn't do like you know I didn't do
like any you know
Koby 19 videos I'm just doing you know
whatever I need to do is just stay low
and stay out the way and this notice
virus came and hit me I just feel like
this you know my place to know later
what he is a very very serious virus and
everybody should take this extremely
serious almost a lot of people like I
said well force a lot of people it's not
you know in the same situation is
immediate I'd be over - you know react
the way we have I just want everybody
take this super serious and be mindful
of it so what's your what's the
diagnosis you're getting about how far
you might be in and how you know if
you've contact traced anything I know
again you just found out yesterday but
I'm wondering what you've been told
about how you when you might have gotten
this and how much longer you may have
here before you're you're feeling a
symptomatic completely we can only we
can only truly go off at the positive
test so I took it I took the test three
days ago whenever we took whenever I
took the test I had been feeling sick
for about for about three days but I
can't really you can't really count
those days because you don't really you
don't really know exactly what's going
on I know for a fact whenever I got
tested that was the day I can start
quarantine so three days ago that's
where I started my 14 day quarantine and
are you buying right now are you by
yourself completely now LaVon or I mean
no I'm not I'm not um no I'm not by
myself and that's a I feel like you know
is that's another you know I know says
waiting that was just fortunate for me
you know I had um well my security uh my
security was here with me and whenever
they quarantined my house we all just
got they all just assumed like we all
had polio nineteen so we're all just
here is following us well here at my
house and you know we're all going
through this together so last one for
Yvonne I mean you hear so much talk
about when's the country going to open
up and how sports is being mentioned
frequently as the indicator as to when
we can go back to
now that you have Kovac 19 do you have
any thoughts on on what you think the
proper the proper circumstances need to
be for you to feel comfortable going out
there and being a member of the Denver
Broncos with your teammates and and and
opening things up like what what has to
be done first in your mind I just I feel
like is I whatever safe and you know
this is a great situation that you know
the whole world is in you know we really
don't we really don't know it's not a
lot of you know in fruit it's not
amazing for us to say okay safe to go
back tomorrow all safe to go back you
know last week you know I feel like
whatever it is they're safe I feel like
whatever it is they're safe that's what
we should do up close take our time but
really just you know figure all this out
you know if I can get it you know so
like my health is like my health is my
number one priority
well if this happens you know somebody
that would a compromised immune system
would it be you know totally it would be
totally different
so whatever whatever steps that whatever
steps that we take are just going to be
the safe ones you know if we playing
football if we playing football and
empty stadiums or you know if we got a
quarantine away from our families before
we meet up and go to training camp or
you know whatever is that we got to do I
just I just wanted to be safe so we can
get through this and we'd be done with
it
Vaughn I hope you're done with this fast
and I think what you're doing to share
it and get the word out to people is
crucial so I give you the last word here
before I send you on into your Friday
and and hopefully a a restful day and a
healthy day for you I gave you the floor
one last time I just say one less time
to you know take it extremely serious I
like to think that you know I'm Superman
whenever you know the season you get a
cold you can clean fight do it you go to
practice and you push through it no this
is this is totally different
oh my god so many other people to think
about besides myself and I know my mom
my dad my little brother you know it's a
you know children that I'm around and
it's um it's
bigger than myself and you know whenever
I got the the diagnosis I kind of took a
step back to just think about like
madness you know this hit me and I was
nervous and scared and you know all of
the things that you know people
experience and just you know typical fun
fashion you know I took a step back and
I just thought about like how could i
how can I be what position can I put you
know this information is where it could
be the most impactful and um you know I
just like a man I just gotta you know
tell people that I got it
I feel like you know when people you
know realize that I got especially all
my boys and all my teammates that and
know me personally know how I live and
they know who I am and they saw that I
have in it that I really step up so when
they seriousness around this virus so is
everybody to stay safe there don't stay
out the way take you serious it's for
you Vaughn take care of yourself we're
gonna check back in every now and then
here and and know this I know you
mentioned all the people that you're
you're thinking of and that you're there
for million of fans millions of fans to
millions of your fans that are looking
to you and the fact that you want to set
an example to basically say take this
seriously stay home stay safe as best as
you can and if it can happen to you it
can happen to anybody I think that that
is remarkable and I thank you for being
on the show to help spread that word
thank you always that's von Miller
eight-time Pro Bowler Denver Bronco
right here in the Rich Eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here